[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'avais 10 ans j'étais un garçon
plutôt discret déjà sérieux et je
passais mon temps à faire des dessins
comme ça je je dessinais des bunkers
ultra technologique des bunkers ultra
sécurisée et à l'intérieur de ces
bunkers
il y avait toujours un petit personnage
aux lauriers l'histoire de ce bunker
c'est que il était tout le temps attaqué
par d'une horde de méchants monstres et
en général mes dessins il fini c'est
plutôt comme ça c'est à dire qu'après
une énorme explosion
c'est à dire un énorme gribouille qu'on
soit clair tous les murs du bunker
partait en vrac et qu'est ce qui reste
est mon petit personnage à l'extérieur
j'ai compris que quelques années plus
tard
mais ce petit personnage c'était moi
huit ans après ses premiers dessins je
rencontrais le premier amour alors
général quand on parle du premier amour
on dit que c'est les papillons tout va
bien
c'est la jeunesse tout est facile ben
non désolé pour moi ça s'est pas du tout
passé comme ça pour moi
ce premier amour c'était plutôt un
calvaire j'étais plein de peur plein
d'incertitudes
pourquoi parce que la fille avec qui
j'étais
elle était complètement différente de
moi elle était pleine d'énergie plein
d'émotions plein d' enthousiasme et puis
moi ben moins fidèle à moi même j'étais
plutôt qu'un plutôt poser est en fait
j'avais aucun moyen de comprendre ce qui
se passait en face de moi on me
demandait tout d'un coup d' exprimer mes
sentiments mais mes sentiments j'en sais
rien je n'avais pas du tout ce que
c'était sa rentrée pas du tout dans ma
case d'intellectuels donc je vous
raconte pas ce début de premier amour
c'était très difficile c'était source de
conflit entre nous mais également à
l'intérieur de moi et je dirais même
plus qu'un conflit c'était une guerre
et qu'est ce qu'on fait en temps de
guerre on se réfugie dans un bunker
alors j'ai compris les raisons de ce mal
être quelques années plus tard en
étudiant les travaux de carl gustav jung
young qui est le père de la psychologie
analytique qui est un des pionniers de
la psychologie des profondeurs publie en
un livre qui s'intitule types
psychologiques dans ce livre young nous
apprend que nous avons toutes et tous à
l'intérieur d'entre nous quatre
fonctions psychiques qui détermine notre
façon de voir le monde et également
le juge est en moi je me dis formidable
je commence ma lecture et je tombe sur
la première fonction la première
fonction qui s'appelle la fonction pense
et je me dis intéressant c'est doux
explique que c'est la pensée cartésienne
la pensée logique la pensée linéaire
analytique scientifique
moi je me dis je veux rassurer bon bah
ça correspond tout à fait à ma nature de
scientifiques dix bombes tout va bien je
continue ma lecture là je tombe sur une
seconde fonction la fonction qui
s'appelle senti à sensation alors là
c'est la sensation du monde physique du
monde quantifiable du monde mesurables
et pour un ingénieur comme moi bah ça me
parle ça me parle complètement donc là
je me dis bombe
tout va bien et là je me dis oui mais
non parce que ces deux dimensions ne
représente en fait que la moitié de
toute ma psychologie
je redécouvre qu'en face de la pensée se
trouve le sentiment c'est à dire qu'au
lieu de passer notre temps mon temps à
décider et choisir de façon très
cartésienne façon tableur excel
on peut aussi décider avec le coeur on
peut décider selon que l'on aime ou que
l'on n'aime pas selon qu'on le sente ou
qu'on le sente pas alors moi je dis
c'est un scoop je continue et l'âge des
courts qu'en face de la sensation qu'il
existe l'intuition c'est à dire qu'au
lieu de tout le temps regarder la
réalité sous un angle hyper réaliste
hyper concrets les chiffres de ressasser
les recettes du passé qui ont toujours
très bien marché
pourquoi on changerait eh bien il existe
l'intuition
il existe une façon de voir le monde où
l'on peut changer où l'on peut et on
peut innover où l'on peut inventer où
l'on peut imaginer où l'on peut faire
rentrer de l'invisible dans du visible
alors voilà je fais ou young il entraîne
nous expliquer que ces quatre fonctions
qui sont derrière moi elles sont en nous
elles sont à l'intérieur de moi et elles
sont à l'intérieur de chacun d'entre
vous eyong rajoute que notre travail en
tant que personne en tant qu'être humain
c'est de partir explorer ses fonctions
psychiques
c'est d'aller prendre conscience de ses
fonctions psychiques et en particulier
c'est d'aller explorer les fonctions
psychiques qui nous font le plus peur et
qui sont les plus opposés à notre
première nature & young rajoute que plus
on fait ça plus on trouve une paix
intérieure
alors cette fille qui me causer tant de
soucis cette fille qui me causait tant
de tracas
j'ai compris pourquoi sa personnalité
était tout simplement totalement opposé
à la mienne la suite de l'histoire c'est
qu'au fil des années cette fille m'a
fait découvrir les dimensions de moi qui
était cachée elle m'a fait découvrir les
dimensions de moi qui me faisait peur et
aujourd'hui elle est responsable de
l'homme que je suis devenu elle m'a
aidée à oser elle m'a aidée à se poser
sortir des sentiers battus de cette
trajectoire d'ingénieurs cette carrière
d'ingénieur qui était tout tracé pour
devenir entrepreneur
elle m'a aidée à sortir de ma prison de
rationalité à sortir de ce bunker si
froid si noir si sombre pour m'ouvrir
aux sentiments et vous savez quoi
cette fille
je les épouses est gelée épouser et elle
est aujourd'hui ma plus grande source
d'inspiration et d'épanouissement
alors si je vous dis tout ça ce soir sur
scène c'est pas pour jouer les
romantiques
c'est pour vous dire que ces conflits
que j'ai pu découvrir à l'intérieur de
moi je les vois également à l'échelle de
notre société
ce conflit entre la pensée et le
sentiment eh bien on le retrouve entre
la technologie et notre humanité
cette technologie si froide qui nous
fait parfois peur et notre chaleur
humaine le conflit entre la sensation et
l'intuition
on le retrouve aussi lorsque l'esprit de
la jeunesse veut provoquer le changement
mais qui se heurte aux traditions aux
habitudes à l'histoire
alors là dedans il n'y a aucun jugement
de valeur
on a autant besoin des traditions que du
changement on a autant besoin de la
technologie que de notre humanité
mais il ya une question qu'il reste à
résoudre c'est comment faire en sorte
que ces opposées qui se repoussent et se
divisent puisse maintenant ça tirait
pour moi la solution ça a été l'amour
est pour vous ça sera quoi
[Applaudissements]